Can you believe it?
We've made 50 of these dumb things!
From the
guy who made Batman comics cool again
and the guy who’ll probably make Batman
movies suck again
comes a film based on a graphic novel
based on an older film
based on ancient Greek propaganda
based on a true story...
300.
Before the release of the unnecessary sequel
on a boat
revisit the movie that made guys everywhere
feel really out of shape.
Meet the Spartans, a society built on reason,
sit ups,
and child abuse.
Led by Leonidas, cinema’s yelliest king
"This is Sparta!"
"Spartans!"
"No mercy!"
"No!"
"Regroup!"
"Stay on!"
"Tonight we dine in hell!"
Who hails from the Scottish part of Greece?
"We've been sharing our culture with you all
morning."
Watch as Leonidas and his 300 closest gym
buddies stand against the might of Xerxes,
a hairless giant with an entire jewelry store
on his face
and a voice that sounds like he’s in the
witness protection program.
"I will erase even the memory of Sparta from
the histories."
Lace up your sandals for a blend of historical
truth and Zack Snyder nonsense,
mixing
real Greek battle formations
qith crazy ninja spin moves,
real Spartan councils
with sexy stripper oracles,
and actual Persian fighting units
With mutant Persian goat men?
Huh?
Oil up for the most confusing thing to happen
to teenage boys since calculus class,
full of homoerotic undertones like
Men wearing thongs
Men getting speared with phallic objects
Men holding hands
Men holding men tenderly from behind
Men letting it hang
Men getting all wet in the rain
Men getting all sweaty on the beach.
Men playing two flutes at the same time
Men saying things like this:
“A fine thrust.”
or this:
"Your Athenian rivals will kneel at your feet
if you will but kneel at mine."
And a male-to-female nipple ratio of 600 to
4.
Man, I haven’t seen a movie this deep in
the closet since Top Gun!
"I am dangerous!"
So get pumped for a dumb movie that’s only
cool because of Zack Snyder’s bag of overused
visual tricks
featuring...
Dramatic falling stuff
Instagram filters
And
suuuper
sloooow
moootion.
Come on!
I might as well be reading the book!
Starring...
Gerard Butt
Nick Fury
6 through 300
Dhalsim
Emperor Herpetine
“Hey, You Guys”
Cersei Lannister?
McNulty?
and Michael Fassbender?!
One cool looking movie and now he gets to
make Batman vs. Superman?
Great.
Thanks for watching our 50th Honest Trailer.
Who knows - maybe someday we'll make it to
300!
Hehe, get it?
Ugh.
Please don't forget
to subscribe.